[Music]
now let's uh speak to fazana kochai
she's a an afghan member of parliament
and a women's rights activist
you have decided to stay in afghanistan
please tell us why
um
thank you for having me you know when i
just realized the taliban entered the
kabul and then
uh i just
realized that the president rene left it
all of us beyond and
uh
we have no one here and this that broke
my heart too much and before that i just
decided to be here that i i had a
feeling and i have still a feeling
of
responsibility and
obligation about um
like
uh about my people about women in
afghanistan i just thought that
um this uh this should be
someone should be here like not just one
person
so like we need some people here to
speak up with about what's going on
and uh just um
it's not always about just safe and
securing yourself yes you know because
we have so many
things
back back in our country like our
families our
friends our relatives our colleagues and
all of them we can't just uh
take all of them out of the country
immediately so we have to stay and be a
voice in a moral for all those women
millions of women who can't
uh leave the country and who those who
need
a moral here in a
in a support of moral support in in
order that they are not
they are not
like being killed and
at least or it's not something happening
that uh everyone should leave the
country here we can't leave 35 million
people we are to go who will stay here
then and then just for this to be
advised for the voiceless in the dark uh
time that we are we need
uh
some people uh the most
then other time more than that
you mentioned your your fellow uh
afghans where afghanistan has a very
young population
two-thirds of afghans are under the age
of 20. this generation did not grow up
under the taliban were exposed to ideas
and used to democracy and free speech
will they stand up will that generation
your generation stand up for these
values against the taliban
uh yes thank you the the the
two third of
generation
people in the country just grow grow up
alongside with the growth of democracy
in afghanistan with all the values and
all the the the the good things that the
democracy regime can offer to the people
while we had some problems and
challenges too and because of that we
are now in this situation but still we
were hopeful and we were trying to make
it better day by day so when it comes to
um to
just uh sending back all of these young
young people this generation to back 20
years or uh to uh according to the world
situation sending them to
to uh like the first century of
where people were living without a
government without without a right and
everything else so it won't be possible
uh there will be resist there will be uh
like um
combating that there would be people who
who want to tolerate that and there will
be people who have a feeling yet to the
country and the people and they won't
just just leave everything by leaving
the country they will fight from outside
from inside from everywhere so here uh
in these days as i'm facing everyone
even the the leaders i'm not calling
them my leaders but some people are
calling them their leaders so
just they just all of them just left
lifted that behind like like we have no
one in here as a as a person who can
talk on behalf of us but
mr karzai and mr abdul abdullah that we
have and talking now with the taliban so
in this situation like why they were
afraid why the world why the german are
now talking to the taliban in doha
because they they are afraid of their
personal that
something happened to them
why the youths are talking to them why
everyone in the world and and uh the
leaders the elders the warlords the
everyone that has been in a fun storm
with the power all of them just
going out and without any resistance but
this won't be forever
everyone will come back with with some
potential and with some capacity to
fight the taliban but for now everyone
is uh trying to save and secure
themselves and their family and their
their group and just
just choosing to be silent but in my
opinion we need to speak up at this
moment exactly where the ruling of the
taliban are is not started we we we need
more vices more people more
advocate to to advocate for advocacy to
do advocacy for the people for the
people of afghanistan for the future for
phantom
so here
we can send all these millions of people
to another country and not we are we are
not capable of accepting sending them
sending them back to the uh
allow me to interrupt you please i'm
very sorry to interrupt you but you
mentioned the talks in doha and the
german government that the german
government is talking uh to the taliban
at the moment do you think dialogue with
the taliban should stop altogether
at this point no at this point you know
exactly as you know the taliban are in
control of all afghanistan
we we missed the chances we missed the
places we missed the steps that that
should be taken and we didn't along with
together with
with the leaders with decision makers
with those who were who are in charge
and somehow responsible for the things
going on in afghanistan we just missed
that and now the taliban are in control
of everything
in afghanistan at this point the the
talking to them would be uh
would would be a hope at least at least
for us that maybe it have an effect
while
we are living in a
in being lost and disappointed but still
for the future of our country we can't
just
just we wish we have some hopes too that
if it worked
okay under the old taliban regime you as
a female member of parliament would have
been a target how fearful are you about
the future of women and girls in your
country
uh i can't like i can't have a
clear image uh to talk about in this
regard i don't have a clear
understanding that what will be
happening
i don't know what will happen when the
u.s and allies just leave
like by the end of august what will
happen here who would be responsible who
would be there would be anyone to hear
the voice and even if they hear would be
there anyone to react no at all i don't
i'm disappointed i'm sorry but but we
have been through to so much
disappointness and in this
about the future i found women i don't
have a clear image while we have some
announcements some press conference from
the taliban side
and but we are hearing something else on
the ground as we are living here hearing
of course in these days the things seems
normal but but it can't be like this
this is a situation the taliban just
ordered their fighters to do nothing
with
anything
if we keep everything on their
fazanaku i'm afraid uh we have to leave
it here an afghan member of parliament
and women's rights activist thank you
very much for your time
thank you
now germany's interior minister haas
tsehofer was asked how many refugees
will now come to germany as a
consequence of the taliban victory in
afghanistan let's take a listen to what
he said
there is no prediction
and i've explained to all parties in the
bundestag
why no one can make such a prediction
right now
that's because at the moment there are
published assessments estimations and
much more that as far as i know range
from a few thousand to a few million
million
for more on that we can now speak to the
migration expert gerald knaus
mr claus is
right
well it depends which part of his
statement you refer to if
we refer to his
first sentence that there can be no
serious predictions
well that is certainly right we don't
know what will happen next
but if you refer to the indication that
potentially perhaps there might be five
million refugees
then we need to look closer at the
reality on the ground
uh we don't know the future but what we
know is that a lot of things have
changed in recent years at the borders
surrounding afghanistan certainly the
border is leading towards the european
union
in 2015 millions of syrians could go
visa-free to turkey with their families
the border was open turkey welcomed them
and then some of them were already at
the border of the eu today this is no
longer the case the difficulty now is
getting out at all so
to throw these big numbers into the
debate i think is politically dangerous
and factually
not very useful because at the moment
around the world very few refugees
managed to cross borders that's the real
problem
so
zehova also said that most refugees
should be taken care of in the country
in afghanistan itself
how realistic is that
how realistic is that
i think what he meant and what a lot of
other people in his party have said is
that we should help the neighboring
countries so if afghans have to flee
and they go to pakistan or iran well
let's help these countries and then they
can stay there
now let's
admit it's it's obviously a good idea to
help first countries of first reception
that is what the un global complex for
refugees says but let's also say that
it's not very credible for europe
for rich countries to send a message to
poor neighbors to say listen you keep
your borders open
but we will not take people including
the many hundreds of thousands who've
been helping us or who worked with us
during our intervention
so i think what we need to be looking at
is something
as existed for the vietnamese both
people in 1979 there was a u.n
conference in geneva where a coalition
of countries said to the neighbors of
vietnam
we are prepared to also resettle people
from malaysia and indonesia
but please keep your doors open and this
kind of approach
of supporting neighboring countries
but also offering some resettlement
which worked before when the world was
much smaller and much poorer hundreds of
thousands of vietnamese were resettled
celebrations this is a model we should
look to 2015 we should look to 1979.
you